une enquête a été ouverte à minsk sur la
présence et le rôle de ses hommes en
biélorussie accusé d'incitation à
l'émeute et de liens avec sergueï ivanov
qui un des chefs de file de l'opposition
qui a été incarcéré et empêché de se
présenter au scrutin présidentiel du 9
août
pour le kremlin tout ceci n'est qu'une
méprise même s'il est admis que ses
hommes font bien partie d'une société
paramilitaires leur présence sur place
n'aurait rien à voir avec les événements
politiques en cours nous pouvons dire
maintenant avec beaucoup d'assurance que
ces citoyens russes était de passage en
biélorussie il y était seulement en
transit pour partir dans un autre pays
leur séjour n'a rien à voir avec la
biélorussie où les affaires biélorusse
il faut dire que le pouvoir biélorusse
fait face à des événements sans
précédent lors de cette journée de jeudi
plus de 60 mille personnes se sont
rassemblées dans un parc de la capitale
en soutien à la candidate de
l'opposition souhaitent la nature and of
sky
il s'agit tant que la femme de sergey et
ira nobs qui qui s'est présenté à
l'élection présidentielle dans la foulée
de l'arrestation de son mari et qui ne
cesse depuis d'attirer les foules
alexandre loukachenko au pouvoir depuis
1994 fait donc face à la mobilisation
inhabituel alors qu'il brigue un sixième
mandat consécutif et soupçonne mènent
maintenant la russie de vouloir
l'écarter
s'agit-il d'une mobilisation suffisante
pour détrôner le premier président de la
république biélorusse premier élément de
réponse le 9 août dans la soirée à
l'issue du premier tour